sara is 36 and has struggled with her
weight for most of her life she says
it's not down to a lack of willpower or
exercise instead she says being obese is
down to her biology very much had boobs
and hips at Primary School I mean I
remember having my first Broadway at
Primary School so it was crazy so yeah I
felt different you know I felt out of
place and I couldn't wear the same
clothes as my friends so I automatically
felt like yeah like I didn't want to
look this way you know it was kind of so
I kind of it started from that and then
I think over the years it's kind of got
progressively worse because I've had
phases where I've done well and I've
lost significant amounts of weight so I
lost eight and a half stone about five
years ago I thought that was the answer
I thought you know this is it got to a
point where I was in a I'm still
overweight but I wasn't obese anymore or
classified as at least anymore and I
thought you know this is it now I've
lost the weight and I think a lot of
people do think that they think it's a
destination and the hardest part for me
was realizing that it wasn't too many
people look at people that struggle with
their weight or living with obesity and
think it's their fault and it's a choice
and that they've made that choice to
kind of get there well I can tell you I
haven't chosen to live my life like this
latest statistics show almost 30% of
adults in England are obese the NHS
spends around 6 billion pounds a year on
treating obesity and it's estimated that
obesity is responsible for more than
30,000 deaths every year in a bold move
to deal with this growing epidemic the
Royal College of Physicians is for the
first time recognizing obesity as a
disease and calling for the government
to do the same we've come to realise
that obesity isn't a lifestyle choice
it's something that people have a
genetic predisposition to and it depends
on the environment that we live
recognizing it as a disease allows
people to understand that they have a
disease and removes the stigma or
certainly reduces the stigma of having
obesity professor Rachel bass ahem
specializes in obesity research for
University College London
she says her work backs up the idea that
obesity is a chronic progressive disease
over a hundred different variations in
DNA have been identified that mean that
some people will become obese whereas
other people will be protected we also
know that once a person has developed
obesity it's almost impossible to lose
that weight and keep it off what happens
is the body tries to go back to the
highest weight that you've ever reached
by recognizing obesity as a disease
Rachel says they'd have to be a national
strategy to tackle it involving more
funding and the use of medication to
treat it but this would be a major
change for the health sector and some
experts fail to classify almost a third
of the UK population as having a disease
could bring dangerous consequences I
don't think it's a disease it's a
condition it's an outcome so you or I
I'm slightly overweight I think
according to government statistics maybe
more than that I don't see myself as
suffering from a disease that's because
of the things that I do the environment
which I live my lifestyle so obesity for
me as a condition is not a disease I
don't buy that at all the UK is the most
obese country in Western Europe some
experts feel classing obesity as a
disease could signal the start of
changing this paninis B's and a bacon
and Bri the mozzarella and apple juice
and a cloudy lemonade please Sarah
agrees she has a balanced diet eats
three meals a day and doesn't snack on
junk food she says she wants to
challenge misconceptions and remove the
blame that comes with being obese
Charlotte Lomas Sky News